hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreign again and with the
release of the new season 10 trailer
sakura or better known as the actual
name hito kiri coming out in may 2nd as
well I would like to kind of go over
some of the lore of this character
seeing as he Tokyo is an actual name for
something in the Japanese culture which
we'll get into a little bit later so
there is actually some valuable
information as to where this name kind
of came from and kind of giving us a
little backstory on more sakura the
female version or yato the male version
of this character hito kiri and kind of
where it came from and some more lore
about that as well as talking about the
acts and kind of what it means as well
so I've done a few of these lore videos
on apex legends and I thought that those
would be pretty well if I brought them
over to for honor so if you guys do want
me to do more with the new upcoming
characters definitely let me know I'll
gladly get into that if this video does
well but with that my discord in twitter
will be in the description down below
and let's get started so as i stated
sakura is the newest hero coming to for
honor season 10 the trailer was released
yesterday and it has incredible scenery
with loads of snow or ash everywhere
with amazing visuals throughout the
trailer
I went on the Ubisoft for on her page
and it says Sakura the manslayer it also
says for honor new season and hito kiri
hero coming in May 2nd so we know next
week is actually the release of the new
season which is really exciting news so
mark that on your calendars May 2nd is
the release of season 10 so you get to
play as Sakura or if you don't have the
season pass you'll be able to buy her
for steal on May 9th but as I stated the
name of this hero is probably going to
be hito kiri the female name of the hito
kiri is Sakura and the male name is yato
if this is true then the in-game name
when selecting her will be the kitto
here e so Ubisoft did it again with
giving us better player names in the
actual hero name everyone is gonna be
calling this new hero Sakura and not
hito kiri I'm just gonna call it right
now there really isn't anything really
talked about the hito carrier or Sakura
within the post but I did do some
research and found out a definition hito
kiri is a Japanese name for assassin or
murderer I doubt this but please do not
let this be another assassin type
character we've had so many throughout
the other seasons and I just don't want
another one I was really time for the
heavy characters to come into play it's
highly unlikely seeing as how big this
axis but the translation does worry me a
bit this name was given to a special
samurai named Macao wakame against a
who was born in the 1800s and he was one
of four highly trained assassins in the
Bakumatsu period which is when the
military government was falling around
this time they were so incredibly
skilled and fast with their weapons
these assassins were able to assassinate
their targets and broad daylight without
being caught there was actually an anime
adaptation of this character named
himura kenshin
a fictional assassin meant to portray
him in the manga Kenshin was president
and if you play the game jump for us
Kenshin is actually in the game in there
as well
Kawakami against a studied hard in the
martial arts field but he wasn't good
enough and was ended up being tasked as
basically being a janitor and then into
some pottery and some flower arrangement
but he didn't really complain on his off
time he studied lots of the martial arts
techniques to refine and hone his skills
he ended up later joining the Kumamoto
forces on security but then later
evolved into a personal bodyguard of
Sanjo Sato me but he ended up leaving
after the loss of his master to an
unexpected raid on the temple he then
became an assassin as mentioned before
and like I said he was one of the best
assassins of his time murdering a very
popular politician of the Japanese
culture in broad daylight he then went
back to the military to enlist again but
then he was caught and thrown into
prison in Tokyo which later he ended up
dying by decapitation within Tokyo so
what does this really all mean it means
hito Kari is gonna be a very deadly
character my only issue is while looking
for photos and images I found none with
the great acts only swords even in the
anime adaptation Kenshin doesn't use
axes only his swords but I did find the
name of the axe from the official web
site it is called the MAS Akari acts
another name is oh no but I like mas
Akari better kind of rolls off the
tongue a bit so we're gonna keep with
that name but this word translates the
Japanese word of axe or hatchet
lots of people claim samurai never used
axes but that's extremely incorrect the
definition or the description of the
weapon is a huge heavy axe that needs
great muscle power to wield originally
used for felling long trees and even
breaking up boulders axes were used in
shugendo and by the sahi which were
monks at while shugendo was a type of
religion within Japan but then it was
eventually ruled out by everybody and
separated into what we know now as
Shinto and Buddhism most of the way of
the MAS Akari is on the headpiece as
seen from the Sakura trailer with the
blade being really huge while the handle
is small in comparison this is to make
the weapon cut through heavier
with ease and the whole weapon is
averaged about six feet in length and to
give you a perspective
I'm 511 so this weapon is actually
bigger it by me than an inch and it can
be wheeled with one hand or two handed
stance so we might actually be able to
have a combination of both one-handed
and two-handed strikes or maybe just one
of the stances I really hope it's both
the samurai had lots of training in the
martial arts so the reason the blade is
two-sided is for all the martial arts
techniques to come into play being able
to use both sides of the weapon and
being very deadly with both instead of
neglecting it at one side but this is
kind of where my knowledge ends on this
subject in terms of Japanese culture on
Sakura's armor you can actually see a
little bit of a few doll heads on the on
the armor so someone in the comments let
me know what this is about but I do
believe these are called sunken dolls or
sunken doll heads and this might have to
represent the amount of kills that this
person has acquired now if there are
more I doubt that they're gonna have a
billion of them strapped on their body
if there have killed many people but
seeing as the hito carrier part of an
assassination group and their assassins
and murderers it's most likely meaning
that this is the amount of high-ranking
officials that they've killed there any
assassination targets that they may have
acquired so if that is the case that
means the character we play as Sakura or
yato has killed about three people and
depending on the armor we're probably
going to be getting a lot more doll
heads to maybe signify that we have
killed a lot more people and that's why
we have this high ranking armor yeah but
please definitely let me know in the
comments below about that like I said I
really don't know too much about that so
I'd love to be kept up on with all the
knowledge about this character but yeah
that's basically what is the base big
recap or the big lore or back story of
the new hirohito kiri or better known as
Sakura or yato for the new 4 on our
character in season 10 if you have
anything else to add about the character
anything other notes or backstory that
you may know that I may have [ __ ] up
on or anything that I totally missed
definitely let me know in the comments
below and I'll be sure to comment that
we can start a discussion I'll maybe add
it's the pin comment so I do appreciate
that yeah like I said if you guys want
me to do more of these lore videos and
them in the future for the new
characters coming out we got the Viking
one coming out later in the summer and
then the woollen one coming later in the
fall so I'll definitely be very excited
as long as the information is there I
will definitely do it
the one thing that I didn't like about
last season is that the Vorta Grand the
black priors were made up so there
really wasn't any information that I
could go off of unless I'm blind and I
didn't see anything I couldn't make any
lore video on
because these this was a made-up lore by
the developers where is this this is
total lore from history of Japan yeah
but that guy's like the VP do enjoy a
subscriber for new a cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leak so
if you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world a
foreigner def we stay subscribe to the
channel and with that my Twitter and
discord will be in the description if
you guys want to join that and keep up
with the community and my two most
recent videos are gonna be popping up on
screen during the outro and with that
take care guys and peace out enjoy
[Music]
you
[Music]